You ever catch yourself complaining about your boring life?
because it's normal and stable and there's no chaos in it?
Then you think back about the crazy life
the unsure the uncertainty of your past
and you remember you wished that you were exactly where you were at now
when you were going through all of that chaos
you prayed and you dreamed of the life that you have now
really puts everything in perspective
because I would rather take my boring
normal life over the chaotic past
that life isn't serving me
the life I'm living now is serving me
if you're ever feeling dull or bored
you're tired of your routine
think back about that chaos
really ask yourself is that really what I'm missing